[Musique]
attentat sans précédent en corse le
préfet de région assassiné hier soir
lors d'une embuscade trois personnes
sont placées en garde à vue
condamnation unanime de la classe
politique la superbe victoire des
rugbyman français qui inaugure en
fanfare le stade de france 80000
spectateurs à la fête pour un match de
grande qualité
et puis cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
d'hiver de nagano la neuvième de
beethoven pour accompagner les sportifs
avec demain l'épreuve reine la descente
messieurs de ski
les [ __ ] en choeur avec à 20h50 sur
france 2 le spectacle au zénith 50
artistes sur scène avec en meneuse de
revue muriel robin qui est notre invité
ce soir
madame monsieur bonsoir acte
considérable par la force du symbole
l'assassinât du préfet claude erignac
est la plus grave atteinte à l'autorité
de l'état
jamais enregistrés en corse jacques
chirac les neiges aux spas et plusieurs
membres du gouvernement viennent
d'annoncer qu'ils participeront lundi
ensemble ajaccio a nommage solennelle
dans ce journal me reviendront sur la
condamnation et l'indignation unanime de
la classe politique après cet attentat
mais d'abord les faits il était un peu
plus de 21 heures en plein centre
d'ajaccio
lorsque le préfet a été tué de plusieurs
balles ce soir trois suspects sont en
garde à vue et pourraient être
directement lié à l'attentât
michèle fines jacques cardoze et
jean-françois giorgetti on ne sait
toujours pas ce soir qui a assassiné le
préfet erignac
depuis hier deux hommes sont en garde à
vue la police avait effectué des
prélèvements sur leurs mains et leurs
bras pour tenter d'y trouver des résidus
de poudre
les premiers résultats connus il y à une
heure sont partiellement négatif ces
deux marocains d'à peine 20 ans ont été
arrêtés hier une heure après le meurtre
un témoin avait cru les reconnaître tout
près du lieu du crime
selon cet homme est assassin était comme
de type maghrébin et porter la même
tenue vestimentaire casquette dim et
blouson
à l'ombre des expertises qui sont menées
mais même si cette piste s'avérait très
irritable
elle ne conduirait pas certainement aux
véritables commanditaires
cet après midi la police judiciaire est
revenu sur les lieux du crime
minutieusement les enquêteurs refonde
jour les constatations qu'ils ont déjà
effectué de nuit
ils savent que les assassins ont tiré
trois balles en pleine tête
l'arme du crime un beretta 9 mm et
mènera peut-être jusqu'au commanditaire
le pistolet a été dérobée il ya six mois
dans l'attaqué d'une gendarmerie à
pietrosella en corse du sud
un acte attribué à une branche
dissidente du flnc canal historique ce
matin la concorde façade légale de ce
flnc a préféré condamné le crime
comment bien sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac
et surtout nous donnons au mouvement il
fallait plus les dérives qui ont pu
amener à cette situation
irène scolaire chef de la section
antiterroriste du parquet de paris qui
dirige les enquêtes encore beaucoup à
faire
la police judiciaire continue quant à
elle ses investigations
de leur côté les hommes du raid et de
l'office central de répression du
banditisme ont débarqué sur l'île
discrètement à la mi-journée la honte la
tristesse la révolte la ville d'ajaccio
s'est réveillée sous le choc et avec
elles c'est toute la corse qui dit son
indignation message de condoléances
drapeaux en berne jacques cardoze
jean-françois giorgetti quantité de
fleurs à la mesure du choc et de
l'écoeurement
car c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit
aujourd'hui un sentiment de dégoût
partagé par l'ensemble d'une population
venue témoigner c'est trop c'est trop de
violence trop de trop de maury dutil et
on ne construit pas la corse sûrement
pas on la détruit on la détruit chaque
année un peu plus et c'est une étape
encore qui est qui vient d'être franchie
c'est très grave
je crois que tant
il ya du monde ici je pense que c'est
pour dire non à sa non la violence la
violence ne résout rien jamais une
violence à fait incroyable ce matin à la
lecture des jaunes très vite un registre
de condoléances a été ouvert dans la
journée et chacun a pu dire son émotion
je voulais dire tous mes regrets pour le
peuple corse pour ce qu'on représente
parce que je suis corse avant tout filmé
ici j'ai toujours vécu ici et ça ça ne
se fait pas c'est pas de chez nous et je
sors mon choix comme pêcheur pour une
fois encore ça en devient presque que
qu'au texas n'est pas possible il faut
simplement qu'ils se mettent au moins
une fois par pour tout 4 design est
quelqu'un de l'époux ton projet est ce
un changement de comportement difficile
à dire en tous les cas rares sont les
moments ici où tant de personnes veulent
porter le deuil et la fiche est là et ça
fait des années que ça dure et ça
continuera toujours
aveu d'impuissance face à ce qui semble
être un éternel recommencement
comme si à chaque disparition une part
de l'identité corse disparaissent et
avec elle et ce matin le président
jacques chirac qui s'exprimait sur le
perron de l'elysée a rendu hommage au
nom de tous les français à claude
erignac et a réaffirmé sa détermination
pour que l'autorité de l'état soient
respectés nous l'écoutons l'assassinât
du représentant de l'état en corse est
un acte barbare d'une extrême qualité
est sans précédent dans notre histoire
j'ai exprimé personnellement madame
erignac à ses enfants au nom de tous les
français où l'émotion et mes
condoléances claude erignac d'état grand
serviteur de l'état qui mettait toute
son énergie tout son coeur au service de
sa mission en corse
je réaffirme eux
aujourd'hui ma détermination à ce que
tout soit mis en oeuvre pour que
l'autorité des cas soit respectée fils
de préfet préfet lui-même homme de
devoir et de dialogue claude erignac
laissant corse où il était en poste
depuis deux ans l'image d'un homme de
contact à l écoute de tous il avait
toujours refusé toute protection et se
déplaçait très librement sur l'île agnès
vahramian un nom un titre chuchoter hier
soir dans les rues d'ajaccio
le préfet la corse l'avait adopté depuis
deux ans ici disait claude erignac je
veux rester longtemps encore
sa mission aider l'île à sortir de
l'ornière économique en instaurant la
zone franche mais aussi faire face au
terrorisme en avril 96 c'est lui qui
reçoit la presse pour faire le point
après une fusillade entre nationalistes
et policiers les journalistes le
décrivent comme un homme disponible pour
eux ouverts au dialogue pour tous la
préfecture de région 10 et il est une
maison où l'on peut parler avec
franchise certains se souviennent
d'ailleurs de réunion houleuse avant la
corse claude erignac avait été préfet
dans les yvelines et dans le gers à
ajaccio il ne craignait rien ni personne
d'yves et sans protection rapprochée
sortait sans escorte dans sa vie
publique comme dans sa vie privée
face à la violence son discours était
ferme comme ici après l'attentât contre
la gendarmerie de pietrosella
c'est en effet un attentat important
tout à fait inadmissible tout à fait
stupide
né claude erignac ne savais pas que
larmes qui allait la battre avait été
volée à cet endroit
ce jour-là l'état comme les élus de
l'assemblée corse sont unanimes pour
condamner l'assassinât de claude erignac
et salué sa mémoire le premier ministre
est venu dans la matinée d'hier son
amitié et sa solidarité aux corses en
affirmant que les coupables seront
châtiés parce qu'elle joue c'est bon
emmanuel bec
le signe du deuil et l'hommage de la
république à son serviteur
le gouvernement a tenu à marquer par sa
présence la gravité exceptionnelle de
l'assassinât de claude erignac premier à
venir se recueillir ce matin sur la
dépouille du préfet de région
emile zuccarelli ministre de la fonction
publique suivie par le ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement
devant les corses qui petit à petit on
t'a couvent mais surtout lionel jospin a
tenu à se rendre au plus vite à ajaccio
je suis venu m'incliner devant la
dépouille de claude erignac se trouve
que j'avais connu il ya très longtemps
qu'on nous étions jeunes étudiants et
qui s'est affirmée ici comme un
serviteur de l'état à la fois dans ce
qu'il doit représenter en même temps
dans sa simplicité parce que ceux qui
l'ont assassiné aussi lâchement ont
finalement profité du fait que il se
déplaçait simplement et bien sûr la
représentation démocratique insulaires
ne réagit pas moins solennellement les
élus corses parlent tous d'un long
cauchemar qui continue et de la
nécessité d'un sursaut républicain
nous nous posons la question de savoir
si au cours des dernières années nous
n'avons pas laissé trop aller les choses
dans l'indifférence la passivité et
c'est en quelque sorte une une part à
mea culpa collectif qu'il faut faire
mais il faut que nous nous interrogions
sur l'état de la société corse qui est
dans une situation de délabrement total
et il faut que nous réagissions nous
mêmes d'abord tous les responsables
politiques la miss a thing tnt mêmes
propos
le canton natal paroxysme il n'y a sans
doute autre chose à faire est de l'état
j'attends sa détermination et de notre
communauté
j'attends une manifestation de dignité
et d'espérance
quant au président de la république il
se rendra lui aussi ajaccio lundi après
midi pour rendre un dernier hommage à
claude erignac et nous rejoignant
maintenant direct à ajaccio benoît
duquesne benoît l'enquète on l'a dit
progresse actuellement trois personnes
sont placées en garde à vue et leur
signalement correspondrait au type
maghrébin
absolument et 6,7 cette piste se vérifie
bien il faudrait expliquer comment des
nationalistes corses peuvent être amenés
à faire appel pour lutter contre dans
leur lutte contre la france à faire
appel à des hommes ou des jeunes hommes
donné société marocaine alors d'après
les spécialistes de la lutte
antiterroriste et bien ça ne serait pas
tout à fait une surprise en tout cas pas
une première puisque dans d'autres faits
mineurs cela rend tout cas moins graves
eh bien on a déjà vu des petits malfrats
de banlieue quelquefois l'origine
étrangère enrôlé comme ça par des
nationalistes pour poser une bombe ici
ou là notamment dans le sud de la france
mais si ce n'est pas forcément une
surprise en tout cas ce serait quand
même le signe d'une certaine
déliquescence de ce mouvement
vous pourrez dire qu'il s'agit d'une
sorte de mercenaire utilisé par des
organisations clandestines dissidente
alors c'est un petit peu toute la
question c'est là dessus qu'ils ont
beaucoup insisté monsieur jospin et
monsieur chevènement savoir qui manipule
éventuellement qui commandite qui a pu
armer les bras de ses jeunes si encore
une fois ce sont eux ce qui n'est pas
approuvée pour l'instant pour réfuter
quand même l'un des actes les plus des
terroristes les plus importants qu'il
puisse exister assassiné un préfet de la
république alors dans un premier temps
par an pense bien sûr au flnc canal
historique pourquoi il vient pour toutes
sortes de raisons d'abord parce que ils
ont mis frein à la trêve qu'ils avaient
eux mêmes décidé au lendemain de
l'arrivée des socialistes au pouvoir
ensuite parce que la personnalité du
préfet claude erignac en tout cas son
arrivée pouvait pour eux être synonyme
de ce le changement de politique de
monsieur juppé quand il avait décidé de
laisser tomber certaines négociations
clandestine au profit des arrestations
à commencer par celle de françois
santoni qui était l'un des deux rôles de
leur leader et puis il ya
la proximité des élections régionales ou
territoriales comme on dit ici et là on
peut imaginer qu'un mouvement comme
celui-là est en vie de réapparaître
brutalement sur la scène politique
alors qu'il est en perte de vitesse mais
tout cela n'est pas aussi simple d'abord
parce que la plupart des mouvements
nationalistes ce soir condamne cet
attentat
et puis ensuite parce que cette mouvance
se déchirent de mois en mois de plus en
plus en de multiples groupuscules et
qu'il est très difficile de les
contrôler et bien évidemment de savoir
ce qu'ils font et que cela permet toutes
les surenchères
merci benoît duquesne j'ajoute que dès
vendredi soir renforcement de la
sécurité autour des bâtiments publics à
marseille et à aix-en-provence
et puis contrôle très strict pour tous
les avions et bateaux entre la corse et
le continent
pour l'instant on l'a dit aucune
revendication les organisations comme la
kung pao ont condamné l'attentât reste
une myriade de mouvements clandestins
dissidents qui pourrait être à l'origine
de l'assassinât du préfet de corse
claude sans père comment ne pas se
perdre
aujourd'hui dans le maquis des
différents mouvements clandestins en
corse qui tue qui plastique pourquoi
quand le préfet erignac arrive dans
l'île en janvier 1996
la tendance dure le front historique
parade dans le maquis six ans cagoulés
et fortement armés
l'information judiciaire sur cette
conférence ne sera ouverte qu'un an plus
tard en visite officielle dans l'île le
lendemain le ministre de l'intérieur ne
fait aucun commentaire à l'époque le
pouvoir semble hésiter entre une ligne
de fermeté et une politique de
négociation avec les nationalistes
ce sont deux attentats ont une âme et
vous allez rien fait et parmi eux les
fermes où on va essayer de le rester
vous a vu mais on va faire respecter la
loi comprend 9 octobre 1996 attentes à
la mairie de bordeaux
le premier ministre alain juppé visé le
gouvernement choisit clairement la
fermeté les grands leaders nationalistes
poursuivi par la police rendent ici
françois santoni leader officiel du
mouvement à kongolo officieusement
numéro un du front historique
une fois les grands chefs en prison la
tendance dure va se fragmenter en
plusieurs petits groupes qui se livrent
alors à une dangereuse surenchère le 25
janvier dernier un de ces groupes qui se
présente comme le front historique
annonce une rupture de trêve suivi
d'aucun attentats mais parallèlement un
autre groupe
s'enquiert revendiquent les plasticages
de l'ena à strasbourg et d'une
gendarmerie en corse du sud où l'armé
retrouvée hier le beretta 9 mm avaient
été volés ici aux gendarmes
et ce même groupe sampieru annoncé il ya
quelques jours sa condamnation par
avance de toute action qui pourrait être
menée contre certains fonctionnaires
représentant de l'état colonial comme
aujourd'hui s'y retrouver devant tous
iront pc sous groupes aux communiqués
contradictoires
comment y voir clair alors que ces
groupuscules utilisent parfois des
hommes de main sans passé nationaliste
recruté au dernier moment pour quelques
milliers de francs des tueurs que les
policiers ont surnommés les bébés flnc
nous rejoignons maintenant en direct de
l'assemblée jean-louis debré bonsoir
vous avez été ministre de l'intérieur
dans le gouvernement juppé tous les
gouvernements surtout difficulté du
dossier vous avez joué vous la fermeté
en mettant en présence pour la première
fois des responsables nationalistes
apparemment ça n'a pas servi d'abord je
voudrais rendre hommage à claude erignac
et avoir une pensée pour sa famille
c'est vrai que nous avons eu une
politique de fermeté c'est vrai que la
police sous ma responsabilité a
interpellé de nombreux nationalistes
c'est vrai que nous en avons fait
écrouer plus d'une cinquantaine mais
cette politique elle doit durer car il
ne faut jamais jamais cédé aux
terroristes et je crois que il faut
apprécier cette politique non pas dans
un court moment mais il faut continuer
continuer à faire preuve de la fermeté
car il n'y a pas d'avenir en corse en
dehors du respect de la loi et il faut
que la police renforcés moyens lorsque
j'étais mise d'intérieur il y avait le
raid le crb qui était en permanence sur
l'île et il faut aussi que la justice
fasse preuve de fermeté et de rapidité
et je souhaite que tous les
nationalistes qui avaient posé des
bombes qui ont été arrêtés il ya un an
soit jugé et juger rapidement ce soir
monsieur debré vous vous placez en
dehors de tous les clivages politiques
et vous appeler à la mobilisation c'est
à dire à soutenir l'action de jean
pierre chevènement vous êtes à ses côtés
ont naturellement je crois que la
situation est suffisamment grave pour
que l'on ne fasse pas de polémique et
constitue en dehors de tout clivage
politique il faut que toute la classe
politique quelle qu'elle soit se
rassemblent autour de l'état pour que en
corse la loi soit respectée et il faut
que des corses eux-mêmes viennent un
mouvement une vague de réprobations
parce que toutes celles et tous ceux qui
aiment la corse savent que la violence
ne mène à rien et que la violence ne
peut pas préparer l'avenir de cette
région et de cette île précisément vous
vous demandez par exemple aux élus
locaux notamment ceux de l'opposition de
sortir de leur silence et et de leur
passivité
je souhaite que tous les élus de
l'opposition de la majorité aujourd'hui
plus le problème prennent la tête d'une
vague de réprobation on ne peut pas
accepter ce qui se passe en corse et il
faut que la politique le gouvernement
précédent avait initié cette politique
de fermeté
et bien soit poursuivie avec l'appui de
l'ensemble des élus quels qu'ils soient
dans cette attente a évidemment
s'inscrit à quelques semaines des
élections territoriales
oui naturellement mais peu importe
savoir dans quel schéma il se situe il
est inacceptable les auteurs doivent
être interpellées doivent être déférés à
la justice
et c'est les corses eux mêmes qui
doivent aider toutes les forces de
police à retrouver les auteurs de ces
attentats est à mettre hors d'état de
nuire
celles et ceux qui voudraient par des
agissements violents année la corse à
nouveau dans la dérive
je leur dis parce que je le pense très
profondément
il n'y a pas d'avenir en corse dans la
violente et il faut poursuivre la
politique que j'avais souhaité encore
c'est-à-dire identifiés interpellés et
arrêtés et condamnés tous c'est tout ce
qui pose des bombes ou qui hélas se font
les assassinats merci monsieur debré
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
l'assassinât sans précédent du plus haut
représentant de l'état intervient dans
une corse secouée par la violence depuis
près de 25 ans période durant laquelle
il y a eu d'autres victimes parmi les
élus et les fonctionnaires hervé brusini
des coups de feu claquent autour d'une
société viticole à leiria 22 août 1975
une affaire de trafic de 20 tourne mal
des militants nationalistes corses
occupe la petite entreprise
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
deux gendarmes sont tués c'est le
passage à l'acte au nom de leur cause
des partisans du nationalisme corse
peuvent tuer
l'hôtel fait ch janvier 1980 cette fois
c'est une prise d'otages
ajaccio une vingtaine d'autonomistes
détiennent des clients de cet
établissement qui tous sont venus du
continent
la gendarmerie déclenche un dispositif
sur les lieux à sa tête le capitaine
barril une négociation s'engage
désormais les militants corses ont le
sentiment de pouvoir parler d'égal à
égal avec des militaires la cause vient
de se militarise 1990 les cibles se font
politique
cette fois les élus sont victimes de la
violence en septembre charles antoine
grossetti tombent sous les balles de
deux hommes à moto dans cette station
essence il était maire et membre du
conseil général de corse du sud le jour
des obsèques
parmi la foule le président de la
chambre régionale d'agriculture
lucien trop lawn trois mois plus tard il
sera lui aussi assassiné
la liste est longue cette année là en
fait déjà en 83 le secrétaire général du
département de haute-corse pire genre
masini avaient été abattus et cette
ultime tentative de faire revenir à la
vie le docteur l'a fait j'avais marqué
l'année 80 cet attentat contre un
militant juillet 94 ajaccio toujours
pierre poggioli en réchappe de peu pour
la première fois on vise l'un des
dirigeants de la mouvance nationaliste
les divisions apparaissent au grand jour
elles sont meurtrières
une voiture piégée au coeur de bastia
juillet 96 l'attentât aveugle un nouveau
degré dans la violence
encore un règlement de compte et des
victimes sans rapport aucun avec le
nationalisme une action inimaginable en
corse
plus aucune référence dérives mafieuses
la cause a basculé dans le gangstérisme
des bandes armées se disputent pouvoir
et argent
la justification politique cache mal le
crime de droit commun dans les hameaux
aux voyeurs maintenant quelle est la
marge de manoeuvre du gouvernement on
peut dire que la question corse lui
saute au visage
oui les gouvernements beaucoup fait pour
la corse il ya eu on en a parlé des
tentatives de solutions politiques à
base de discussions secrètes parfois
hasardeuse mais surtout il ne faut pas
oublier que l'état a beaucoup donné un
statut politique particulier instituts
économiques particuliers avec une zone
franche et des aides au développement
que beaucoup de régions françaises en
vie ces dispositions étaient sans doute
indispensable pour corriger des
injustices et reconnaître la spécificité
corse
mais l'élément clé du règlement du
problème corse c'est sans doute la
nécessité pour chacun de jouer son rôle
au gouvernement de faire appliquer
l'état de droit et sur ce point le
gouvernement jospin se situe dans la
ligne du gouvernement juppé
une fermeté qui met fin aux petits
arrangements de toutes sortes à la
classe politique locale qui mériterait
sans doute d'être largement renouvelée
d'appuyer cette ligne ferme et d'en
finir elle aussi avec des attitudes
ambiguës
mais le plus important c'est l'attitude
du peuple corse lui même à lui de dire
d'exprimer son écoeurement face à cette
violence
à lui de manifester peut-être dans la
rue comme contre les assassins comme les
espagnols les basques eux l'ont fait
contre les criminels de letea à lui
d'empêcher que les terroristes
bénéficient d'un silence complice d'un
quelconque soutien qu'ils ne se sentent
plus chez eux en corse c'est au prix de
cette attitude claire de refus du
terrorisme que les corses peuvent
espérer se débarrasser de la violence
est aussi bénéficier de la solidarité
nationale
merci arlette chabot et voilà ce que
l'on pouvait dire pour l'instant sur cet
attentat
nous reviendrons en tout cinq journal
pour un dernier point le reste de
l'actualité avec en polynésie
effondrement de tout un pan de colline
dans l'île de tahaa qui a fait huit
morts et six blessés
cinq personnes sont toujours portées
disparues mais les secours n'ont plus
grand espoir de les retrouver en vie
cette catastrophe intervient après les
pluies violentes et tempête tropicale
qui a balayé la polynésie depuis 2000 à
lyon le périphérique nord sera gratuit
jusqu'à lundi le conseil d'état
en effet annulé la concession
d'exploitation signé par michel noir en
juillet 91
benoît gadret bonne surprise pour les
automobilistes de la région lyonnaise
depuis 6 heures ce matin
théo le périphérique nord de lyon est
gratuite et parfait poursuit fort thèse
ou non reste que c'est vrai c'est quand
même un peu honteux ce tronçon qui est
qui est payant tant mieux ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle et j'espère que ça va
durer
théo est gratuit car depuis hier soir le
périphérique n'a plus de
concessionnaires
le contrat avec le consortium bouygues
dumez a été annulée par le conseil
d'état car contraire à une directive
européenne
en principe pour les abonnés ils ont le
droit de demander le remboursement de
leurs abonnements depuis son ouverture
le périphérique construit sous l'ère
michel noir est boycotté par les
lyonnais car jugé trop cher
cent dix mille personnes ont signé une
pétition pour la gratuité alors que
l'écologiste etienne tête déposer un
recours
aujourd'hui la communauté urbaine
présidée par raymond barre peut soit
racheté les ouvrages soit signé une
nouvelle concession plus favorable à
l'usagé
en attendant le périphérique sera fermée
à la circulation à compter de lundi soir
au chapitre politique après
l'invalidation par le conseil
constitutionnel de l'élection de jean
marie le chevallier hier il annonce que
sa femme sandrine sera la candidate
front national à l'élection législative
du var qui sera organisée dans les trois
mois
du sport à présent divine surprise pour
le quinze de france qui a baptisé
dignement par la victoire le stade de
france 80000 spectateurs en liesse pour
une rencontre de grande qualité
christophe duchiron et frédéric bazille
avant dans les bons jours on les appelle
les princes du parc maintenant qu'on a
changé de stade on les appellera
peut-être les rois de france et
aujourd'hui c'était pas les rois
fainéants
c'était des vrais rugbymen tout en
musclant chaliand que
avec de vrais spectateurs en peinture et
la marseillaise à 80 une loi avant
d'aller au combat pour croire que
l'ambiance a rendu les anglais blanc
comme leur maillot parce qu'en première
période la france surprend la france et
tone minutes ça la france el mar 11
minutes de jeu philippe bernat-salles a
récupéré la très belle passe de philippe
benetton et c'est pour les bleus qui
mène 7 à 3 toujours en première période
voilà les français qui remettent une
couche de bleu une belle attaque de
trois quarts comme avant et pour finir
le ballon à christophe dominici première
sélection dominici qui fait son affaire
des défenseurs anglais
à la mi-temps la france mène 15 à 3 pour
ce comparatif bien
à la reprise les zambiens reprennent
leur émotion et une charge comme des
engagés dans la vie de françois pour le
propane s'est conclue au possible
n'empêche backes a marqué attention les
blancs sont de retour
mais la france mène encore 18 à 11 paul
greyson la filière en chef de l'équipe
de sa très gracieuse majesté marque une
nouvelle pénalité 18 à 14 dieu sauve la
france mais aujourd'hui les bleus
n'avait besoin de personne pour couvrir
ces télés voit la défense les rois de la
reine les rois de france
dans les dernières secondes de jeu ça
donne il a passé un drop entre les
poteaux et ça soulage tous ceux qui
supportent les bleus victoire pour la
france 24 à 10 sec dire que c'était
attendu nine n'agiront pas c'était en
tout cas fortement espéré c'est l'esprit
et le coeur qui a prévalu aujourd'hui et
on était soudée on n'était pas 15 ans
n'était un seul aujourd'hui et c'est
west était une belle image très heureux
très heureux d'abord d'avoir battu les
anglais parce que c'est vrai que c'est
les rivalités trésor d'avoir gagné
surtout au stade de france aussi pour
l'inauguration
et puis très heureux aussi pour mes
coéquipiers parce que je pense qu'ils
ont fait une partie
aujourd'hui beaucoup de générosité et de
solidarité il ya trois mois après une
cuisante défaite contre l'afrique du sud
la france avait perdu son équipe de
rugby après quelques mois de recherche
on a retrouvé un quinze de france
franchement ça fait du bien
[Musique]
c'est donc cette nuit que se sont
ouverts à nagano les dix huitième jeux
olympiques d'hiver
une cérémonie riche en symboles avec
dans cinq continents par satellite
l'hymne à la joie de beethoven repris
par une chorale mondiale et les sumos
comme on vit à les vouloir à l'image
[Musique]
dans moins de six heures maintenant
débutera l'épreuve reine de ces jeux
olympiques d'hiver la descente messieurs
une descente où l'on attend un exploit
français jean luc crétier nicolas burtin
vont tenter de réussir là où luc alphand
a toujours échoué
pour france 2 le dernier vainqueur de la
coupe du monde de ski a repéré la piste
aux côtés de laurent frédéric bollée 8
et jour cette piste il faut la bichonner
une descente olympique c'est souvent une
vitrine pour les jeux pour savoir ce que
vaut celle ci un guide s'impose luc
alphand le tout jeune retraité et nous
livre ses premières impressions
bienvenue à hakuba lors de la descente
hommes c'est parti c'est parti pour 3289
mètres exactement une longueur qui
répondent aux critères de la fédération
internationale de ski mais il a fallu
quatre ans pour y arriver les japonais
voulait en effet une piste plus courte
le site étant paraît-il protéger quatre
ans de polémiques pour un compromis
trouvé il ya deux mois seulement
mais tout semble prêt c'est de la glace
bleue et c'est un bon souvent on le voit
pas la télévision mais toutes les
courses maintenant sont préparés de
telle façon que la piste ne casse pas
pour les derniers et à la limite on
pourrait dire que c'est les meilleures
conditions pour faire une course au plus
c'est dur au mieux c'est la pente
moyenne est de 30 % la vitesse maximale
approche les 120 kilomètres/heure luc
alphand s'y croirait presque
et l'arrivée de descente alors on lève
les bras sur la gagner à voir à quoi on
voit surtout que la piste n'est pas le
boulevard que certains redoutaient elles
réservent beaucoup de passages
spectaculaires les difficultés existent
personne n'est à l'abri d'une erreur de
toute façon maintenant que le tracé a
été entérinée tout le monde a oublié la
polémique
laso sport je crois c'est pas la
longueur qui est tellement important
effort une certaine langueur c'est clair
mais c'est la technique et les
difficultés là puisque trois français
sont ici en position d'être médaillé ce
matin jean luc crétier a réalisé le
deuxième temps du dernier entraînement
crétier l'ami de luc alphand près
peut-être à l'imiter c'est à dire à
gagner la grande soirée des [ __ ] sur
france 2 dans une quinzaine de minutes
le concert au zénith une cinquantaine
d'artistes avec en meneuse de revue
muriel robin qui est notre invité mais
d'abord place aux images quelques temps
forts de ce spectacle exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
non
lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et toi
chez sa cousine
l'ensemble est
[Musique]
gueule
moi
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez l'émission s'est dit surprise
mais voilà un bon soir vous est la
marraine de cette soirée et vous êtes
meneuse de revue de cette cinquantaine
d'artistes soirée unique exceptionnel
quelle est la marque de fabrique de ce
zénith 98 écoutez il ya une marque de
fabrique est là tous les ans mais qui
est là à chaque fois plus forte
c'est vraiment une soirée magique pour
nous mais je suis sûr pour les gens qui
vont la regarder il ya effectivement une
cinquantaine d'artistes les mêmes des
nouveaux on a vu quand on a une
merveille mathieu fait je veux pas pour
les découvrir
je crois vraiment moi quand j verte en
attend tous nous les artistes ce soir et
avec impatience je crois je le ressens
tout cas quand on l'a fait les artistes
viennent avec le meilleur d'eux mêmes
les seuls le reste aux vestiaires il ya
quelque chose qui se passe qui est
absolument unique
il faut regarder cette émission il faut
la regarder parce que vous ferez partie
d'une chaîne de solidarité qui commence
par les emmerdements qui ont besoin des
restos du coeur qui passe en tout cas
pour ce soir par nous il faut la
regarder parce que ça doit être envie
d'acheter les vidéos et que ça reviendra
sur un repas l'année dernière cette
soirée en tout cas les vidéos ou
engrangé 18 millions de français
beaucoup de repasser 10 % du budget
total de l'association les restos du
coeur voilà et en quoi l'esprit de
coluche est toujours présent dans cette
manifestation qui est ce soit en tout
cas un immense divertissement coûté sur
leur mettre un nom sur l'esprit de
coluche jeu j'ai pas pensé mais il est
question d'humanité de solidarité de
coeur sont les restos du coeur
comme je vous le disais les gens à ce
moment là laisse parler cette chose-là m
ca devant voilà donc donc il faut aller
on va et c'est comment dire
c'est vraiment quelque chose mais
vraiment c'est j'en ai encore l'émotion
ce que c'est vraiment quelque chose de
fort qui se passe et qui va aller
jusqu'au j'en suis sûr c'est un moment
vraiment unique
on vous sent très militante pour ça je
veux galette ce n'est pas ma nature mais
pour ça oui
alors sans dévoiler toute la soirée
quand même quelques moments forts
quelques surprises au delà des moments
forge des lacs cette année là on
s'améliore d'année en année on a
toujours peur moi je me dis toujours
comment la prochaine va pas être aussi
beau l'année dernière j'avais un
souvenir formidable c'est encore au
dessus cette année parce qu'on a fait
une mise en scène on a des les artistes
sont en costume alors ça permet de vous
d'un coup s'oublie son costume donc il
joue un peu la comédie cabrel devient
gademann est un garçon très drôle moi je
l'avais jamais vu comme ça et on a
effectivement des gens nouveaux d'été
d'un décor et les artistes reviennent
plus souvent tout au long de l'émission
c'était une fois qu'on les a vus on les
revoit aux comptes les missions et les
moments de comédie
donc elle qui sont très drôles et voilà
ça fait une soirée encore une fois
unique fort qu'il faut regarder pour
pour un moment de solidarité bien sûr et
de bonheur j'en suis sûr aussi vous
allez nous surprendre vous même j'espère
en quoi compte mais les avions ont marié
avec un truc a plus qu donc marié un
peuple maya bizarre mais je les soirs il
va surprendre parce qu'elle est vraiment
différente
je remercie muriel robin et je crois
qu'on aura compris votre message
j'aurais que l'on retourne en corse
avant de refermer ce journal pour faire
un dernier point est ce que j'ai benoît
duquesne en ligne je pense que je suis
en ligne mais oui vous voyez maintenant
vous allez donc ici devant la préfecture
un mot sur les gardes à vue qui se
prolongent elle pourrait d'ailleurs se
prolonger quatre jours puisque nous
sommes dans un une matière que l'on
nomme terroristes
et puis un mot aussi sur l'ambiance
qu'il y ait ici lille paraît choqué
presque stupéfait de voir revenir cette
violence qu'elle croyait banni ou tout
au moins
écarté depuis quelques mois c'est pour
cela sans doute que les syndicats les
partis politiques commencent à
s'organiser pour essayer participer à
l'hommage solennel qui sera rendu au
préfet claude erignac lundi à 16 heures
en présence du chef de l'état et du
premier ministre
et puis me parvient cette dépêche nous
en parlions tout à l'heure les trois
suspects sont bien d'origine marocaine
comme nous le disions et l'un d'eux a
été relâché
bien sûr davantage de développement de
notre édition de la nuit ainsi se
termine ce journal je vous rappelle
l'essentiel le principal titre attentat
sans précédent en corse le préfet de
région a estimé hier soir lors d'une
embuscade
trois personnes sont placées en garde à
vue condamnation
de la classe politique météo dans un
instant isabelle martinet 20h50 donc que
les [ __ ] en coeur le grand spectacle
au profit des restos du coeur
demain dans thé ou café catherine ceylac
reçoit jacques lang midi polémique
michèle cotta aura comme invité nicolas
sarkozy et reviendra bien sûr sur
l'assassinât du préfet de corse
je vous remercie de votre attention je
vous retrouve demain soir à 20 heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]